régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france registre merci d'être avec nous
alors on va contextualiser un l'armée
sur place a reçu une information selon
laquelle il y avait une voiture une
toyota blanche toyota corolla blanche
qui représenterait une menace tout mis
longtemps pour l'aéroport de kaboul et
quelques soirs après en seulement
quelques heures après l'armée frappe
cette même voiture n'est-il pas eu trop
de précipitation écoutez il ya une
expression numérique inquiet a ajouté
l'insulté à la blessure et on a
l'impression que c'est un peu ça qui se
passe l'insultent c'est
la catastrophe de cette évacuation qui a
été fait on se demande comment les
américains n'avaient pas pu prévoir au
niveau des services de renseignement la
chute de kaboul même s'il l'avait estimé
mais elle s'est fait beaucoup plus tôt
elle s'est fait beaucoup plus vite et
donc là dans la précipitation menace
d'attentât de donc état islamique dans
le khorasan donc la branche de dèche
afghane et cette tragique méprise ou une
famille en fait tu disparais par
missiles hellfire tiré sur la voiture
donc oui il y avait en effet dû
renseignement qui laissait penser qu'une
mais un véhicule blanc de type toyota
corolla était pilotée par un kamikaze il
s'avérait que c'était un simple père de
famille l'explosion la seconde explosion
qui a laissé penser aux américains que y
avait des explosifs c'est une bouteille
de gaz qui se trouvait à l'intérieur du
véhicule d'un usage totalement comme en
privé enfin n'y avait pas du tout de de
bombe à l'intérieur et donc voilà donc
ça a été je pense à un malheur de plus à
ce cette espèce d'état l'âge de la
retraite américaine qui restera dans les
mémoires comme un tournant finalement
dans la guerre un tournant si dans
l'histoire du monde quelque part et puis
on se pose cette question quelle est la
qualité la fiabilité même les
renseignements américains c'est un c'est
quelque chose que moi je me pose en
particulier
dans la mesure où quand j'étais à kaboul
en juillet j'avais eu l'occasion de
rencontrer l'ambassadeur de france david
martinon
qui m'avait expliqué tout simplement
comment la plupart des
des traducteurs des réseaux de commandes
enseignants etc qui avait souhaité
partir d'afghanistan avait été déjà
rapatrié donc il y avait déjà les
français avaient déjà affrété quatre
avions pour rapatrier les gens ayant
servi leurs intérêts en afghanistan et
un cinquième se préparer dès le 17
juillet il y avait eu ni l'ambassade de
france avait dit attention c'est la
viande la der des chances prenait le pas
ce que nous selon nous nos
renseignements les choses vont se
précipiter et on avait l'impression que
les américains au contraire même si près
préparer leur retrait mais l'horreur
réparer ans avec beaucoup plus de
sérénité donc la question du
renseignement quant à anthony blinken
dit nous ne pouvions pas savoir que
l'état libre en ariège allait arriver
aussi rapidement et que cette crise
allait se produire sur l'aéroport de
kaboul j'ai quand même quelques doutes
ou alors le renseignement américain
n'est plus à la hauteur de ce qu'il a
été ou alors les français avaient eux
anticipé à partir d'autres
renseignements je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé je ne suis pas dans dans
cette partie mais en tout cas il ya
clairement eu voilà une sorte de de
cascades de 2 d'incohérences qui ont
mené à ce qu'on a vu ces scènes sur
l'aéroport avec des gens qui se
précipitent qui tombe des avions d'aidé
des c 17 qui ont qui prennent 600
personnes à leur bord enfin bref quelque
chose qui voit là marquera l'histoire
comme une un point finalement une
véritable humiliation une humiliation
pour l'amérique
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir été en direct avec nous